in 1983 American psychologist Howard
Gardner published a book with a theory
that there are nine types of
intelligence to understand this theory
let's consider the problem of the
Council of Newtown who wants to build a
bridge over the dangerous railroad
tracks but there is strong opposition
from some citizens who don't like change
despite the demonstrations the council
agrees to go ahead and then hi as a team
of nine experts from smarts encode to
get the job done
let's introduce each one of them miss
pitcher smart played a lot of
hide-and-seek when she was young and she
loved puzzles she has lots of
imagination and ideas about shapes her
job in the project is to create the
plans make the designs and build a
prototype
mr. nature smart loves trees and he has
great ideas of how to minimize the
impact of a bridge on the environment he
started thinking of these issues ever
since the first time he went summer
camping with dad he developed a passion
for all living beings misses number
Smart is a nerd she always was in the
playground
she was already calculating the sand
buckets needed to build the biggest
castle in high school she was the chess
master and everyone was so proud of her
she will calculate the costs study
workers safety issues and estimate the
raw materials needed her concerns are
the budget resources and risks mrs.
PeopleSmart arranges a Town Meeting and
goes out to invite all the citizens to
come she was always good with people as
a kid she spent most of the time outside
with her neighbors as a teenager her mum
explained to her that most people mean
well even if they have trouble showing
their feelings today everyone loves her
and she does a great job convincing
everyone even the most outspoken
opponents
miss word smart has been keeping a diary
since she was young in maths class she
wrote poems and during field trips she
didn't talk to others but instead
studied the Travel Guide for the big
town-hall meeting she writes a
convincing speech filled with hard facts
big feelings and good metaphors ever
since he was young
Jimmy lifesmart knew how to talk and
entertain today he shows his skills on
the stage he starts his speech with a
personal story about his cat that once
got lost on the train tracks then he
delivers all the arguments with so much
passion that all citizens can only agree
with the plan miss wood smart is
delighted to see the impact of her work
now as construction starts mr. Boddy
smart gets ready to get things done even
the children are inspired by his power
and want to help during the breaks he
plays football with his team which is
fun and teachers and balance skills he
later canoes high up in the sky
[Music]
Madame self smart knows a lot about
feelings our fears joys and angers she
learned this from her own past where she
started to reflect on herself but she
also reads a lot about feelings and
talks to her friends about their
emotions during the construction
she is the positive force motivates
those that feel down and solves tensions
that can come up when we collaborate
while everyone is busy finishing the
bridge
mrs. music smart writes a song for the
grand opening she has loved music ever
since she started playing the piano
later she moved on to hip hop and jazz
dance at the opening ceremony of the
bridge she and her band performed the
song it was a fantastic team effort from
all nine of the smart anko
in 2016 gardener said that he is
considering adding pedagogical
intelligence or teach smart what do you
think is he right or wrong about these
types or IQ EQ or other forms of
intelligence better classifications
please be teach smart and tell us what
you think about intelligence theory in
the comments below
[Music]
you